Oi bom dia Brasil boa tarde boa noite
não sei que horas a assistência kdx que
vem formato com o Denilson não sei
quantos anos você tem mas eu Marcela tem
30 anos em quando estava crescendo os
anos 90 era latente por mais feliz que
fosse auxiliares meu redor existiam um
Jardim Felicidade Envia essa esponjinha
cultural Prometi a mim mesma não fazer a
cirurgia principal por hoje é só
rapidinho só câncer com Peixes e obra já
foi mas continuando nossos Marcelo
Esponja tá aqui o material visual para
você entender quais eram os conteúdos
direcionados as mulheres durante vários
momentos bom temos 10 representatividade
e diversidade de Corpos desde os 11 anos
aprendendo como agradar
bom obrigada Capricho quantas dietas
caminho na vida só invisibilidade nossa
capacidade intelectual e quem é saúde
mental resultado dessa equação era
Justamente que me doe ver aí felicidade
feminina são a obras nasce com propósito
claro uma plataforma de conteúdo que
traz felicidade feminino através de
conteúdos relevantes e novas
representações imagéticas recentemente
eu perguntava Qual deveria ser um fator
decisivo você deverá imprimir ou não e
reflexiva pensando em quais são os
empreendedores mais felizes que eu
conheço quando eles têm diretamente
entende que eles tinham em comum é que
deseja entender também o seu lugar
financeiro ou de metas traçadas por
terceiros são aqueles que viram que o
mundo seria um lugar melhor perguntas
mais interessantes com aquilo que eles
falam tem necessidade de pare e digo
para ir quase que totalmente tá que ter
um negócio é quase Como ter um filho por
isso eu digo quando eu
a ideias até influenciadores Amei o
plano de negócios Mas cadê os valores
propósito e valores para mim não são
negociados
é uma vez que você encontra seu
propósito é como eu falei cobre a
sensação E como diria ou por um daqueles
aha moment ou famoso elétrika saber que
aquilo que você foi feito para fazer
quando uma na faculdade fechado o olho
tentar imaginar no futuro eu sabia mais
ou menos que eu queria mas não era
possível mas não é exatamente e hoje eu
sei disso por um motivo simples o nosso
modelo de negócio ainda não existia para
não parecer também a grande visionária
do século também não existe Instagram
Netflix WhatsApp e até poderia
É mas eu não sei eu podia até enxergar
de uma Nebulosa mas sempre foi óculos e
é óbvio e é sobre felicidade feliz e
um propósito claro vamos parar segunda
etapa como tangibilizar esses valores
como de fato ser uma agente de
transformação da publicidade Afinal
quantas agências Você conhece os valores
dela que você sabe naquela acredita até
coloquei ela morreria Pois é eu queria
fazer as campanhas que farão quebra seu
que era feito até então o mercado
precisava conhecer a obra esse primeiro
porque ela era depois pelos jogos
um toque de conto de fadas me torto mas
totalmente Milênio não havia Band grande
escala é que chama o que quiser para a
construção de um site Então vamos no
Instagram então literalmente mirei no
portfólio mas acertei na comunidade é
chato demais percorremos por números
porque afinal o que que significa um né
eu posso dizer para vocês que hoje a
gente tem meio milhão de seguidores mas
para mim o termômetro beijão esse
cotidianas quando por exemplo tava
correndo no parque villa-lobos eu fui
duas meninas na nossa expressão
chapadinha agindo alfena onde é bem
engraçada que valeu como carne para mim
quando eu me despedir desconhecido no
meio na academia dando bom dia e elas me
responderam com Bom dia Óbvio muito mais
que seguidores o que elas têm hoje é
cérebro e podem te vender mil e uma
ferramenta mas é verdadeira pesquisa de
relevância e amor pela marca mora é
claro no Twitter claramente negócio da
plataforma podem ser café mesmo por
cadelinha tudo bem a gente tem muito
orgulho e senti muito carinho
a unidade inferno todo dia a gente sente
responsabilidade o que faz lugar os
últimos anos a pergunta que mais me
fazem sobre a tal da forma uma ótima
então todo mundo laboral laboratório
prático de como construíram tô tô
falando feminina tendo como causa
principal o Instagram me dá umas existe
a verdade é que a publicidade nessa
tarde venda de produto ela também é
fotografia Cultural de um tempo e como
você que está retratada nessa fotografia
do nosso tempo se já existe algo igual
como você quer ser lembrados Como que
foi o professor daquilo ou dos
seguidores os seguidores são lembrados
o Ronaldo escuro só falar sobre saúde
mental a plantação dos meninos vêm nas
palavras de projeto verão que eu preciso
coragem para desafiar apresenta todos
começaram que não tem como negócio
fantasma para mulheres questionando
nesse mês mercado e Deus me livre me
colocar no lugar de grande conselheira
mas Nessas horas é preciso se concentrar
entender que existem dois lugares aquele
que acreditam que você deve estar e o
lugar onde você quer estar essa resposta
eu não tenho seus pais não tem seus
amigos menos ainda então mesmo
professores tem porque os meus ajudaram
demais mas só você consegue fechar os
olhos entender mesmo que de forma
Nebulosa o que você quer trazer um Eu
tenho um bichinho que mora em mim que
obriga tudo que eu falasse útil para
quem tá escutando esse inclusive um
segredo também da construção do
Fernandópolis a perguntas Chaves aquele
conteúdo deve ir ao ar ou não é se você
compartilhar e como amiga ou seja um
tweet existem mil formas e curso sobre
como construir uma comunidade como têm
engajamento por aí vai para mim um pouco
mais sim as pessoas precisam
e quanto mais eu usava aquela mensagem
você usa o seu WhatsApp o DM da melhor
amigo atende como tal pode festa Seus
avós e aqui a mostrar verídica maior
alcance credibilidade daquele Impacto
Afinal você confia mais em público
invadir o seu filho ou com o nome da sua
rede tire no grupo das amigas Então se
existe uma fórmula Talvez uma seja mais
ou menos assim um conteúdo que parece
que fala com você diretamente somado a
um desejo incontrolável de compartilhar
com essa soma temos alcance
multiplicados sem investimento de mídia
paga mas também está sendo a felicidade
do Fernando e ao mesmo tempo dando um
truque laborista
E tu vai para onde você me Vale pelos
copos de hoje então vale para óbvias mas
também vale para esse nosso papo de hoje
eu desejo que vocês então que esses
minutos você era algo de útil para você
e para ser o último Márcia se eu quero
falar mas também eu gostaria de ter
escutado quando estava na faculdade eu
não sei que algumas coisas entre que sem
paranoias spoiler geralmente atenção
mesmo se você quer realmente criar um
que nunca foi feito um lá para seguir à
risca do Conselho de um é diferente
quando eu fundei a obra eu tinha 25 anos
e eu vi algumas pérolas que balançaram
mas que se provaram ser totalmente
falsas por exemplo que uma agência
jamais poderia essa mídia que o mercado
nunca ver se ele vem hoje não que as
marcas femininas ruim ou fecha a contato
com a plataforma questionada pelas
haviam feito a pele respeita os mais
velhos entenda onde que ele tá vindo e
não joga nada fora mas se quiser você
que chamar aquilo que você tem mais
certeza encaro como distrações é
essencial contar é assim mesmo de
coragem para continuar esse status
em toda escolha pede renúncias e tentar
gravar todo mundo eu amo saiu do Cível
cura 2020 esse ninguém aguenta conviver
com uma pessoa que tá sempre morna para
isso tudo que tá acontecendo no mundo
como vai Estou na frente uma marca que
se comporta dessa forma alguns
aprendizados que infelizmente era força
mas que eu falo abertamente é que num
dado momento me preocupei tanto com a
felicidade feminina esqueci da
Felicidade dessa mulher aqui e Claros
também vale para os homens por isso vale
sempre lembrar que você não é o seu
trabalho você é o que você ama a sua
família seus valores a sua intimidade o
seu trabalho é sua ocupação eu lavo
descanso a sério o que seja lá na cabeça
faz com que eu achei que você me deu de
volta ficar disse ela foi valorização do
último a sair do escritório não tem
final de semana é velha cafonice
incentivo pessoas e usar os caras não
são felizes e gente feliz não enche o
saco e falando e oxigenação nessa vida
podem tirar tudo
e você sabe nunca parei de ler nunca
pare de aprender hoje os posts mais
compartilhados temos podcast mais ou
menos nobres não quer edital testados em
outros podcast nem de outro instagram
Guilherme de livros conversas mais
valiosos que só provam que se todos
devem de uma mesma fonte os resultados
você sempre similares celebre as suas
vitórias e saiba que significava suas
derrotas sentir que você não fez bem o
trabalho não significa que você não tem
feito em trabalho menos ainda que nunca
mais vou trabalhar pela internet como
escritório likes como moeda de troca
fazendo que a gente pega a proporção e
velocidade real da vida lembra de
respirar em cima da liderança guerra do
mito de que ela precisa ser um lugar
Solitário não caia nessa Peça ajuda a
sente ajuda incômoda seus aliados
é o que queremos o final do dia é que
aquelas 10 lavadoras se tornem verdades
absolutas em nossa sociedade futura por
fim têm duas palavras chaves para você
disciplina e coragem disciplina é
liberdade coragem bege com coração muito
obrigado tá